hiya Patrick made a video host
evaluating weekly and today I want to
talk to you about the three people we go
to and we're going through a very
difficult time in our lives
[Applause]
[Music]
you know life is pretty interesting
isn't it you know no matter how good we
are or how great we are or how bad we
are doesn't matter we're all going to go
through some tough times but when we go
through tough times there are three
people we tend to want to go see right
and the the people we see and and and
what we do with these people will see
will determine a lot on what happens
with our lives if it keeps improving or
if it stays the same let me talk about
the first kind of people we like to go
see when a challenging time happens in
our lives for instance it could be a
relational problem you and your spouse
are going through a tough time maybe a
breakup maybe separation maybe it could
be a job you got fired or promotion was
passed up on you or it could be health
challenges you know you're having a hard
time with your knees your ankles your
weight it could be something you're
going through wealth health challenges
and we go to one of these three people
but the first kind of people would like
to go see it's just to kind of make us
feel good about ourselves and I call
them to pick me up er here's an example
of a pick me up er so what are you
saying what I'm saying is all I really
want is someone to hold me and tell me
that everything is gonna be alright
alright so that kind of gives you an
idea about to pick me up or write the
next kind of person we may go to I like
to call the Socratic advisor and here's
what the Socratic advisor could look
like you feel like you're alone we'll
what give a soul mate let me define that
somebody who challenges you so it kind
of gives you an idea the Socratic
advisor asks a lot of questions you
thinking but here's the last one the
last one I like to call the excuse
killer this is what an excuse killer
could sound like this is the favorite
thing that I have understood
and rocky marciano give me dad you know
what it was his cuff link huh and now
I'm giving it to you
and it it's gotta be like like an angel
on your shoulder T fine if you'll ever
get away and you feel that you go down
making love you okay you know this scene
from Rocky never gets old every time I
hear Mickey's voice it just gets me
excited you know when I was a little kid
watching rocky but anyways let's go back
to the three different characters so you
got to realize that there is not one
that is more important the other one
this doesn't mean the pick me up er is
more important in a socratic advisor
than more important than the excuse
killer
in a sports team sports teams typically
have all three characters playing in two
quarterbacks mind or the lead players
mind that somebody picks them up
somebody takes the excuses away and
somebody questions them to make them
thinking but what I want you to think
about is the pros or cons of each one
because you know if you only go to the
pick-me-up or the pick-me-up is gonna
say things like this you know that
person doesn't know what they're talking
about honey you're awesome you're great
I love you so much if I would then you
know I would give you the promotion if
your husband doesn't know this your wife
doesn't know how special you are they
got to figure out their due boyfriend
doesn't know if you only go to that what
the pro is is you feel better the con is
you're not improving then you have the
socratic advisor the Socratic advisor is
great because they make you question
things that they say things like well
how do you think the other person feels
based on what you did why do you think
that person is so upset with you why do
you think you didn't get the promotion
why did you get fired what could you
have done better to not get fired at
your next job you know those kinds of
questions and you sit down your question
and you say well that's right maybe I am
being kind of selfish maybe I'm only
thinking about myself and the last one
the the excuse killer they just don't
buy any of your excuses and a lot of
times we don't like to go to the last
one because the last one is just gonna
you know give it your ride back and tell
your making about
excuses you are being lazy you got fart
beat I would have fired you myself as
well there's a reason why they fired
you're not improving you know you make a
bunch of excuses you know you you're not
exercising there's a reason why you have
back prompts when's the last time you
went into the gym your diet sucks they
give you that message so it all becomes
more on you right and you know when you
look at this whole thing it's important
to categorize people in all those three
hours you could have one person that
plays two roles one person could be the
excuse killer and the socratic advisor
you could have somebody that's a very
good you know pick me up or and Socratic
advisor right so you got to determine
those three people in your lives but who
you go to the most will say a lot about
you because if you only like to go to
the pick-me-up on well you're not
improving a lot and if you only like to
go to the excuse killer you're not you
know making yourself also know that
you're not perfect you don't need to be
perfect so all of those balance each
other out for you to be able to take
your business yourself your leadership
level your your identity to a whole
different level
it's my message of the week um please be
sure to subscribe and share this video
you